no one works harder than me the bigger  the Enterprise gets the more specialized  the skill becomes and the deeper The  Well of experience the people need to be  they have to be more specialized in the  beginning small business owners have to  learn a little bit of everything because  you are everything but that Mantra will  kill you and so when people are like I  can't be outworked you're bragging about  the wrong thing it should be like I  can't be out recruited I can't be  outmanaged no one can build a culture  like me that's super high leverage  across the organization no one can lead  like me but no one can outwork me it's  just an irrelevant activity Metro you  have to do some work sure I love working  I work all the time but I would never  claim that